on le sait le coronavirus a laissé de
nombreux français sur le carreau parmi
eux les étudiants qui rencontrent de
grandes difficultés
je n'ai donc pas assez d'argent pour
pouvoir manger trois repas par jour j'en
mange donc un seul face à cette
situation inextricable certains
commettre le pire au cinquième étage
vous pouvez le voir il n'y a plus de
vitres il ya un plateau puisque c'est
actuellement là où il a sauté
heureusement dans ces moments difficiles
certains héros tom leur main à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin c'est le cas de
brahim restaurateur propriétaire du
restaurant l'étoile de fès à mantes la
jolie en région parisienne pour
découvrant la situation dans laquelle se
trouvaient les étudiants il a décidé de
faire preuve d'une solidarité qui fait
chaud au coeur en effet il a annoncé
qu'il offrait aux étudiants les plus
démunis de quoi manger
ce soit étudiant raison s'ils sont dans
le besoin d'aidé nous voir on leur
propose son hamburger son attaque au sol
au coût de très peur mais pour la
personne dans le besoin dans sa plus
féroce un peu le père hyper plaisir et
ça peut lui remonté
un geste qui fait du bien dans ces
moments où les bonnes nouvelles semblent
rares
[Musique]
et mumbai je kiffe prime exceptionnelle
pour moi tu es le héros du moment
merci franchement bravo mon brahim
combien d'étudiants viennent de voir
tous les jours ça dépend si on peut en
avoir 30 40 par jour comme on peut en
avoir zéro comme on peut en avoir dix en
fait on ne compte pas on les considère
comme des clients lambda
ouais il ne compte pas y viennent y
manger ça change rien pour nous en fait
alors ils vous disent quoi quand il est
dans votre restaurant ni viennent de
là-bas la plupart c'est pour ça que j'ai
laissé mes messages privés ouverts et
mon numéro de téléphone
la plupart y soient les appels soit les
envoie un texto pour se renseigner pour
savoir si c'est vrai ou pas et quand ils
sont bas comme sont rassurés viennent
les récupérer à manger et repartent avec
le sourire alors dans la vidéo qui vous
a fait connaître il ya une étudiante
fadoua qui était reconnaissante de votre
initiative en garde et qui pourra pas
engager un peu ce côté solidaires qu'on
doit tous avoir en situation de savoir
que brahim fait décevoir de repas
gratuits pour ceux qui sont en galère
ben ouais c'est que du plus et ça met du
baume au coeur
alors ça c'est magnifique mais moi la
question que tout le monde se pose est
que les téléspectateurs doivent se poser
combien de temps vous allez pouvoir
tenir financièrement
ben en offrant des repas gratuits en
fait avec l'initiative ou qu'on a lancé
on a reçu beaucoup pas énormément mais
on a reçu quelques dons moi je le
faisais déjà de de bon coeur je les fais
de tout mon coeur pour parce que ça me
fait plaisir parce que parce que c'est
ma mission j'ai un commerce doit faire
croquer ceux qui sont en galère
et voilà ça va durer le temps que ça va
durer et le jour je vais plus au pouvoir
je vais dire j'arrête ça mais je pense
pas que ça va ça va s'arrêter de suite
brahim en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire je voulais juste vous faire un
grand coup de chapeau ce soir donc il ya
un gros coup de chapeau s'affoler
relisez la formidable et qu'on a besoin
de gens comme vous n'avez surtout en ce
moment mais est franchement brahim c'est
exceptionnel ce que vous faites et si
vous avez besoin de quoi que ce soit ces
besoins que je vous aide dans n'importe
quoi vraiment je serai là pour vous
sachez le tout le temps je serai
toujours là et vous le savez et vous
n'hésitez pas ça fait super plaisir
merci aux vidéos votre restaurant à moi
j'ai posé la question à monsieur il à
votre la jolie en face du lycée syndex
moi ça fait ça fait quatre ans l'actuel
devant le lycée du coup je suis assez
sensible aux lycéens des
leurs mandants les pièces des fois ils
veulent ils veulent ils veulent manger
ils ont pas à ces pièces ou sinon il ya
un pote ki vien manger un grec et
clotilde le regard bat obligé de ses
gestes
tu es obligé tu peux pas rester
insensible à la situation en fait oui
nicolas non ce que je voulais dire c'est
que il pratique ce qu'on appelle le
cheese burger suspendu comme le café
suspendu est ce que vous direz ça vous
être installée c'est important parce que
ça permet quoi ça permet quelques écarts
un peu plus d'argent de me venir mon âme
cheeseburger et d'en prendre un moment
quelqu'un qui passera un moment donné
très bien la solidarité est très
important c'est ça dont on a besoin on a
besoin de tout le monde
bah merci en fait en fait il ya le
principe du qg de cheese burger suspendu
avec l'association ams de mantes la
jolie
c'est bien ce que je connais pas moi
c'est en fait le projet n'est pas rien
si ce burger vous payez un cheeseburger
que vous mangez pas vous garder un que
nous ont gardés corps n'arrive à 30,56
on l'appelle l'association il faut une
marotte et les redistribue est d'accord
tous à table qu'on en achète une
cinquantaine de cheeseburgers alors lui
c'est le fils de bernard tapie on doit
servir au sial ça on achète on achète
bien sûr dans la section 5h50 qu'on te
donne avec plaisir commerce sinon c'est
pour les redistribue c'est vrai merci
beaucoup ben fête en fête et à le
préciser justement c'est là que je dois
y avait vraiment des barreaux
à ces nuits bravo bien sûr c'est lui
c'était pas des autres qui a dépensé
citoyens c'est tellement ça représente
tellement nos valeurs d égalité
fraternité ce que vous êtes juste une
main frais berne à égalité fraternité
dans ces moments là des gens qui
représentent ces valeurs là avec tout ce
que ça comporte
il a estimé aussi que tu les reçoivent
tout ça génial j'adore brioni où on
parle de 5 et surtout ce serait bien
qu'ils aient beaucoup bas et most hid
justice et on allait en principe du
cheese burger suspendu qui est un
principe a pas qu'en moi j'ai vu la
vague de l'étude gens qui se suicident
est content quand ils ont eu leur la
réunion que le président emmanuel macron
10 plénier tout ça ça m'a fait de la
peine et je me suis dit c'est pas
possible qu'un étudiant qui est le futur
de la france qui fait des études dit moi
je n'ai pas toujours toute l'année ou
même pas qui l'a qu'il n'a pas les
moyens de qui se suicident parce qu'il
n'a pas les moyens de manger j'ai fait
ça juste pour leur venir en aide et
c'est tout à fait normal quoi ils ont du
jour brahim vraiment vous êtes
formidables merci à dieu c'est juste
humain merci à vous merci de m'avoir
accueillie vous êtes le bienvenu si vous
venez tous avec lui vous êtes les
bienvenus moi je ne sais pas très loin
d'ici ça alors ça m'a mis deux jours à
chicago qui habite mantes-la-jolie
également merci mon chéri plaisir